so I'm here with Jeffrey Rosen head of
the National Constitution Center in
Philadelphia and we're continuing to
talk about article two of the US
Constitution which talks about the
powers of the President and now we're
gonna focus a little bit on the first
part of section 2 which talks about
among other things the that the
President shall be the
commander-in-chief of the army and navy
of the United States essentially the
military of the United States and you
know this seems like there's a bit of a
balance here because an article 1 which
describes the powers of the Congress in
the section 8 it says the Congress shall
have power and it starts listing a bunch
of stuffs but what a bunch of things but
one of the things that it lists is the
power to declare war grant letters of
marque of marque and reprisal and make
rules concerning captures on land and
water so how do those two things fit
together Jeffrey
well they've led to the most dramatic
constitutional controversies in American
history as Justice Robert Jackson put it
in the steel seizure case these cryptic
words of the commander-in-chief Clause
have given rise to some of the most
persistent controversies in our
constitutional history everyone agrees
that Congress has the power to declare
war and once war is declared the
president has total control over the
conduct of the war their civilian
control of the military there's a single
leader once the war starts but how the
president can act to deploy the troops
in the face of emergencies when Congress
is silent and how much Congress can
constrain his power has led to rise to
some huge constitutional controversies
and this steel seizure case that you
talk about this was in 1952 this was
arguably talking about the Korean War
what was the context there why why did
this need to be ruled on well it's an
amazing case and the steel companies are
gonna go on strike and President Truman
decides this is a threat to national
security because the army needs steel to
conduct the Korean War so he decides on
his own without congressional
authorization to seize the steel mills
as part of his authority his military
authority as commander-in-chief and this
goes up to the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court strikes him down they say
he can't seize the steel mills on his
lawn Truman is shocked he's appointed
many of the justices but the most
influential
opinion in the steel seizure case is the
concurring opinion by Justice Robert
Jackson I want our listeners to go check
it out on the web because it's so
important and justice Jackson identified
three categories of executive power the
every law student learns in there
they're easy to remember basically when
the president acts with congressional
approval his authority is at its height
when he acts in the face of
congressional disapproval his authority
is at its lowest ebb and when Congress
has neither approved or disapproved the
president acts in a zone of Twilight as
justice Jackson said it sounds like the
twilight zone and I was think of that
music doo doo doo doo doo doo but it
means that in the steel seizure case
although the Congress had not authorized
the seizure and the President had no
civilian authority to seize the steel
mills so he had no independent authority
to rely on in this zone of Twilight and
therefore the court held he acted
unconstitutionally and Truman's argument
might have been hey look the
Constitution makes me the commander in
chief if I read that broadly I should be
able to do whatever I need to execute in
times of war Steel is a very important
input into making other things that you
need to execute your war with and so if
they're gonna go on strike that's gonna
keep me from being able to conduct our
war that's exactly right that's just
what he argued and although some
justices bought it including justice
Chief Justice Fred Vincent Truman had
appointed a majority of the Supreme
Court said that civilian power over the
military doesn't authorize the President
to use his power in the United States in
ways that might be helpful to the war
effort he needs explicit congressional
approval for that it really upset
President Truman he invited the whole
Supreme Court they actually invited him
for drinks at justice Hugo black house
after the decision came down and crewman
salt for a while and he said Hugo I
don't think much of your law but by
golly this bourbon is good and another I
guess relevant this isn't a case but a
resolution is war powers resolution 1973
historical context were nearing the end
of the Vietnam War what was the
background there
well Congress was very upset that
President Nixon had sent bombers into
Cambodia without congressional approval
and there'd been others disputes about
the president's power in Vietnam so
Congress decided to try to codify
exactly when the president could act to
repeal sudden attacks which everyone
agrees that he has the right to do so
Congress said President you've got to
notify us within 48 hours of the time
that you send troops on your own and you
can only keep those troops on the ground
for 30 days except under extraordinary
circumstances otherwise you need
congressional approval so despite this
effort to kind of set out congressional
approval for these extraordinary
situations some presidents have argued
that the War Powers Resolution itself is
unconstitutional as a violation of the
president's commander-in-chief power
others on the other side is that
Congress is seating too much power to
the president but so far the Supreme
Court has not struck down the War Powers
Resolution and presidents are supposed
to abide by it although sometimes they
haven't President Bill Clinton sent
troops into Kosovo without following the
work Powers Resolution and notifying
Congress what's the argument that a
president would make that the war prop
that the War Powers or any one could
make that the War Powers Resolution is
unconstitutional that somehow conflicts
with section 2 the argument is that the
president's unitary authority under
Article 2 gives him complete power as
commander-in-chief to conduct military
operations as he thinks best and that
includes the ability to send troops into
the field despite the explicit provision
in article 1 section 8 of the
Constitution that says that Congress has
the power to declare war so the unitary
executive people and and president
george w bush's administration claimed
this explicitly say that the president
basically can do whatever he thinks is
necessary to preserve national security
that led after the terrorist attacks of
of 9/11 other presidents including
President Obama said that because of the
commander-in-chief clause various
attempts by Congress to limit the
president's unitary authority were
unconstitutional and the Bush
administration said the forbidding of
torture of detainees warrantless
surveillance the detention of US
citizens as enemy combatants all of
these were unconstitutional the supreme
Court rejected many of those claims
including most famously in the Honda and
roms
Rumsfeld case in 2006 where the court
said that the president could not set up
military tribunals without congressional
authorization so the big lesson from all
these cases is that when the president
acts side by side with Congress then the
Supreme Court tends to hold executive
power but when this president acts
unilaterally on his own especially in
the face of congressional disapproval
the Supreme Court is likely to slap them
down but across all of this there is a
even though these cases especially the
ones we cite seem to limit presidential
authority to some degree there's this
general notion even our founding fathers
thought of which is yes you the Congress
has the power to declare war but as the
commander in chief what if we're
suddenly attacked by someone obviously
you don't want to go through the process
of getting all the congressmen together
in a vote you need to be able to act
quickly so it has always been understood
that as commander in chief the president
could engage in conflict quite quickly
no question about it and presidents have
done so from the beginning the response
to 9/11 is a famous example as well but
many of the framers thought that
Congress's approval was necessary for
serious Wars the war of 1812 there was a
former declaration but there were lesser
uses of force like the war with France
in 1798 conflict of the Barbary States
in Tripoli in Algeria conflict with
Native American tribes all of these are
approved by Congress although without
formal declarations in the modern era
though things have really changed and
presidents have used military force
without express consent from Congress on
lots of occasions the Korean War Libya
granade Grenada Lebanon Panama Noriega
on all of these in our cases where the
president has uses force without
congressional authorization and we
haven't had a formal declaration of war
since World War two I mean that
statement I think is worth writing down
that's why since since World War two I
mean when I when you say that to me it's
like well what's it kind of feels like
well we've clearly had what you and I
would consider wars since World War two
Korea via
more obviously post-911 what happened in
Afghanistan we have the Iraq war after
we have both the Iraq Wars and you've
had all sorts of military action about
you know whether we're talking about
drone strikes or kind of kind of very
surgical interventions and all of those
were done without a formal declaration
of war by Congress so to what degree
does this even matter anymore it seems
like in modern times presidents are able
to do what they they need to do
militarily well that seems right now
that's not to say Congress has enacted
many of the wars we've talked about have
had informal statutory authorization
including most famously recently the
authorization of the use of military
force after 9/11 which was said to
authorize a lot of what happened after
9/11 and it's now contested whether that
continues to authorize the war not
against al-qaeda which it was originally
passed for but also against Isis but it
certainly seems to be a case that formal
declarations of war have now been
replaced with these more informal
authorizations or even with presidential
unilateral action and I guess maybe one
argument there is that in some of these
wars it gives more flexibility to the
president to be flexible and there might
not even be a state to declare war
against that's true although there have
been a bunch of these Wars where there
are clear states Korea Libya Grenada
Lebanon more literalist conceptions of
the president say the president could
happen should have asked for formal
declarations of war but that's not the
way that the modern executive has
evolved fascinating well well thanks so
much Jeffrey this this is really
informative thanks it's a pleasure to
talk